oh my i'm gonna tear up simon the way
you just encapsulated that
[Music]
we live in a world of oversimplification
news is given to us in sound bites
in fact everything is given to us in
sound bites if you can't do it in about
140 or 180 characters
people won't have the attention span to
listen or pay attention
things are getting shorter smaller
and dumber
not for phoebe robinson she's a comedian
producer actor all-around remarkable
human being who believes that we need
complexity we need nuance in the work
that we do why
just makes it better
it makes it smarter and it makes it more
important
this is a bit of optimism
when your new book came out
yes please don't sit on my bed in your
outside clothes i didn't even have to
open it i was like
oh oh she and i can be friends
right
because this is a complaint i have had
with
almost everybody i've ever dated in my
life who like comes in from the outside
and gets on or worse in my bed
oh my god and i'm like what are you
doing they're like i'm getting into bed
i want to take a nap i'm like no no no
no no no no no those clothes have been
on the subway those clothes have been
outside
bed is a place for pristine
like that's why you wear pajamas or
nothing like only the thing that belongs
in the bed is what goes in the bed
nothing from the outside world
100 i agree and you're the only other
person
i've ever met
and you wrote a whole damn book about it
well you know it's not a whole book
about it but you titled the book can we
like just get into it if we want to get
into it in terms of dating and all that
stuff yeah cause you're obviously you're
very successful
you work really hard you're on your
grind on your hustle
like are you in a place where you are
prioritizing finding a partner are you
sort of just like if it happens at this
moment cool but i'm focusing on simon i
made a deal with myself many years ago
when i started with start with y and i
started to get invited to speak and
travel
i recognized that it
you know if i pursued this it's going to
hurt my personal life i mean it was
obvious you know i'd be on the road so
much i'd go on an amazing first date and
i'd say oh my god i had such a good time
are you free for a second date in six
weeks
you know so i was
pretty undateable for anybody that
wanted anything serious and i made the
choice that
that i was going to pursue spreading
this message
because it really mattered and i knew
that it would come at personal sacrifice
and i was okay with that the deal i made
with myself was
that when it found its own momentum that
i would re-prioritize
and and as things started to go and they
and i didn't have to be out there
pushing the flywheel by myself every day
like social media and other people like
books that all helped
i could refocus
so i'm in that space my personal life is
very important to me and i will turn
down work because something at home
matters now and i am dating somebody
and it's wonderful and i like being in a
relationship i mean i've had
relationships prior
yeah that's not like this is my first
one
but but my mindset is very different and
covet also had something to do with that
as well
i believe that there's no such thing as
bad or good everything is balanced you
know like everything good comes at a
cost
and everything bad has some sort of
advantage or lesson built in you know
everything is balanced
and so i'm curious for all of the stress
and fear and horror and sadness that
goes with a global pandemic
i'm curious
what you gained i think
the biggest thing that i gained was
perspective
which is really cool because it's not
necessarily like this tangible thing but
it's a life-altering thing in a way
and i've been working in comedy
entertainment going on
what is it 2022 so we're talking almost
14 years at this point and
you know much like your your career it's
like you kind of just if you're like i'm
going to do this i have to
give all of myself and so i was just
hustling i was grinding i was like work
came before everything family friends
you know relationships all that stuff
and then
when covet happened and we had to just
sort of stop and like all these work
commitments that i have for 2020 sort of
like dried up and i was like well what
does this mean i have this business i i
made all these plans i was doing
everything right as opposed to as if
like me being morally a good person
is going to prevent a pandemic from
happening you know what i mean
you know i was really sort of like
mentally struggling my work is a big
part of me so who am i without that part
being as president as it was i was sort
of thinking about starting therapy and
then my boyfriend and then a close
friend of mine were like yeah we think
he should just do it just let's just do
it like once and see like what's up and
i was like all i've never done it before
and it really just allowed me to sort of
be like
as much as i want all my dreams to
happen and i want to do the tv shows and
i want to produce and i want to keep
writing books there's more to life than
just doing and creating and i think it's
very easy when you love what you do to
have it be like well
i love this thing so i want to keep
doing it but it's like
i won't i miss weddings i've missed like
you know
friends having kids like i just have
missed a lot of things that now at 37
i'm sort of like i don't want to keep
missing stuff
and i don't want to keep missing my life
is what i felt like i was doing you know
that's such a great lesson right that we
are worth more than the work that we do
i see this with successful people their
whole self-identity is
tied to their work that when they stop
doing that work they literally have an
identity crisis you know they retire or
they get fired or whatever happens
something goes haywire in their career
and they're they have crisis
i wonder how many people had that mini
crisis during covid when they were faced
with that image before it actually
happened it's like a crystal ball
yeah i think so many people because it's
like
you know
listen there's certainly the capitalism
aspect of things you have to work to
sort of live and support yourself
if you have
dreams that you want to come true you
have to put a lot of energy into it and
so
i think it's easy to kind of get caught
up in
the work of it all and the pursuit of
things because the world is sort of
built to like keep moving and pursuing
and building and acquiring and more and
more and more so it's easy to get to
lose that perspective and see like oh
what am i actually missing out on here
you do so many different things
your polymath is there a thread that you
try and weave through everything
whether you're writing or producing that
you you have something you're trying to
spread something you're trying to
instill in others you know i think
especially in the world of comedy comedy
changes so much and i think it often
can not only reflect what's happening in
society but also help society sort of
change course right and i think
specifically with comedy for a while it
was very sort of cynical
and sort of like i'm gonna be detached
and i'm gonna be removed and that's kind
of cool because i'm checking out this
[ __ ] and i think you know certainly
with the pandemic we're sort of coming
into a place of like
i want to laugh because i give a [ __ ]
because i'm emotionally invested and i'm
laughing even harder because i recognize
that thing it's the old jester's role
the one person who can tell the truth to
the king yeah
who has a perspective
and is willing to speak out about irony
or nonsense yeah and like i want to have
fun and be light
and
be celebratory about life but then also
have like a lot of heart too like i i
just think like some of my favorite
comedies they have so much heart
i think people could just shortchange
comedy as like oh you it's like light
you just turn your brain off and you're
like not even thinking but i think
you're not
really let like when you're really
laughing super hard at something
sometimes it can just be like a silly
sort of like physical pratfall but it's
because you recognize something that or
you've experienced that or
you know it just means something to you
that it it captures your heart and it
hits you where your essence is and that
makes you laugh a lot too back to the
question i asked before so what's your
cause like what's the thread what's the
commentary that you want to weave into
all of your work to make sure that it
shows up i want
people to feel
without
turning it into
judgment making it like about well i'm
righteous
because i feel this thing now
and i think it's very easy to get on
your high horse and be like i'm perfect
i'm smart because i felt this thing
whether it's joy whether sadness whether
it's rage
i got it and you didn't get it because
you didn't get it when i got it
and i want people to just be able like
no just be able to experience the world
without it
being a competition i get caught up in
that too sometimes where it's like
you get so caught up in well i figured
this out so everyone else should have
figured this out already and it's like
well there was a moment where you also
didn't know yeah
so can you give me an example from your
own from your own work where that really
is a crystal clear example of you want
it to be your own journey it's not a
competition have all the feels and if
somebody hasn't had the feels yet
support them rather than berate them it
comes across i think a lot in in my
writing and sort of
how
if i'm going to make a commentary about
anything on the outside
i'm going to address myself first
and be like
hand in the air i [ __ ] up about this
thing
you know when you run your own business
and you're like a boss you make so many
mistakes all the time you're just like
[ __ ]
okay
i know that now and so i think
being a boss in general has been
probably the most humbling thing because
you think boss you're like i'm gonna
have these cute like i'm a ceo outfits
i'm gonna have like the nice
you know tv you're like i want to have a
nice chair for my back and you're like
[ __ ] why the [ __ ] are you worrying
about chairs
i remember the first time i got a nice
chair
yeah and so i think you know for me one
of the biggest things i learned right
away is i learned such a higher level of
compassion
yeah
because
you know your employees are people
they're gonna have good days they're
gonna have bad days and you can't judge
them for the bad days
and um ignore the good days and so if
you see someone sort of like struggling
you could be like bottom line or you
could be like [ __ ] i've had weeks where
i've just been off yeah and i have to
be like that's okay that's normal and
like work through it and so i think it
you know sort of going into being like
it's just about achieving genes and like
knocking everything off the to-do list
and it's like no this shit's like it's
hard and
people are going to respond to certain
things in certain ways and you have to
be open to that i think this is one of
the great gifts of kovid when it comes
to leadership which is you know we we
judge people at work almost entirely on
their performance
you're a good performer you're a bad
performer you know but kovid forced us
to see everybody as human right because
a we saw them in their homes
we sometimes saw their pets their kids i
didn't even know you had kids you know
and it made it all a little more patient
you know because you know there were
interruptions and we were fine with it
and i think we understood that we were
all going through something and when
somebody's performance was down our
instincts for the first time are natural
instincts we're not to judge performance
but to be like are you okay
yeah and so one of the questions is how
do we tell the stories that help us
remember and bring the feelings back
so that we can remember to be the better
versions of ourselves
and i think this is part of the role of
the entertainer
which is to remind us of the stories to
show us and remind us
whether it's dramatic or comedic it
doesn't matter but
the best stories are the ones that you
left sort of like
i got to be a better person at the end
of it back to what i was saying before
about sort of this kind of cynical air
of comedy i think
now it's really because of covet it's
like you want the truth yeah you know
what i mean and so i think that is
a really interesting place i think that
comedy and drama are both sort of
circling right now i think people want
to be seen
i really do think that one of the great
things about kovid
is that it forced us to have
conversations with ourselves
now
that we ordinarily would be having in
like 20 years
we're having conversations with
ourselves like what does happiness mean
and do i want the life that i have and
the great resignation
which is a real thing
i think is part of that you know
in the past most people would define
their job as fine like a very very small
percentage to get to say i love my job
it's great
a very very small percentage it's the
most toxic thing in the world they get
berated at work every day it's you know
it's probably too many but it's
relatively speaking
you know to all people working a small
number most people
unfortunately if you say how's your job
they say it's fine
is it great no it's
it's fine would you like to quit
yeah yeah but you know it's it's it's
it's fine and the problem is is the
unknown
of quitting
is way scarier
than the status quo
and so we make do and i hate to say this
we probably do this in relationships as
well but you know we make do with okay
because unknown is scary
and what kova did
is some people got furloughed some
people lost their jobs some people just
had fear and uncertainty even though
they kept their jobs
and we were okay our relationships are
intact and all of a sudden the unknown
became a lot less scary
and if i'm comparing fine and unknown
now
i'll take unknown what i think is so
interesting about the great resignation
is that it's affecting all levels inside
a company especially lower levels so
it's your frontline worker
who for decades has been mistreated and
abused because companies knew that they
needed the paycheck and they could get
away with it and for the first time ever
that frontline employing is being like
no i'll take unknown it's an indictment
on leadership and the manner in which
we've built corporate cultures over the
past multiple decades
it has been so unbalanced against your
average employee
that this to me it's like a stock market
correction this is a rebalancing and
it's going to go off balance the other
direction for a short period which is
what the great resignation is but it'll
find equilibrium and what i hope happens
for equilibrium to happen is the quality
of leadership goes up the quality of
corporate culture goes up and that
average frontline employee can say no i
like my job i'm happy and fine becomes
the minority
i love all that that was so smart
i was like i wish i was taking notes
well
the good news is i've recorded all of
this
i do have a quick just question based on
what you just said so we are both very
lucky for us to love what we do yes not
everyone's gonna have that
if
someone's just like my job is fine
isn't that also
okay for like you're like say you just
want to be like middle class
fancy right like you want to have like
you put in your i don't know 45 50 hours
a week you have your weekends off where
you can be with family friends hobbies
blah blah but like your job is not
it's fine it's whatever
isn't that also okay as well i don't
know so my intonation of fine and your
intonation are fine or different when i
say fine i'm not thinking about yeah
pays the bills and i'm really happy and
i love my life when i say fine i mean
like the corporate culture that i go to
work to every day the people that i work
with the manner in which i'm treated by
my leaders is fine when i talk about
fine i mean literally like it makes me a
little bit not depressed but it makes me
a little bit sad
[Music]
because i bring fine back home
and then i sit on the couch and my home
life is fine and my relationship is fine
and we're active participants it's not
just like the office has to give me this
i'm like yes yes that's a part of the
equations like in your relationship my
my boyfriend has to do this true and you
have to also
reciprocate
yeah like it's a relationship
it's a relationship and i think that's
been forgotten
i think all of this has been forgotten i
think we've forgotten that we're in
relationship with each other in life
we accuse each other like the left and
the right and whatever the cause is you
know we forget that
we're in a marriage
it's like we live in the same country we
live in the same cities we share the
same resources
and like we're going to have to figure
this out at some point because like
we're in the house together
and like this is what i lament i lament
the fact that we are partners in a
relationship we are one part of a
relationship and it doesn't matter who's
right or wrong we're going to have to
figure this out
the thing is
if it feels like we're no you're 100
correct in that but what i find i'm not
saying who but what i find is
certain people
do not want to respect others you can't
live in a space where you're going to be
disrespected based on
race uh gender sexual orientation how
you identify so it
i don't know i just feel like we live in
such a world of toxic negativity where
it's much easier to say something shitty
or to be like hey did you see this
horrible thing that happened over here
let me like retweet that or or post that
as opposed to like posting something
positive or interesting or
something that can't be boiled down to
extreme reactions and actually requires
nuance and i think the biggest thing is
that we've we've lost nuance uh amen we
have turned this world into bi it's it's
all binary and we've forgotten that life
is complex to your point it's nuanced
and we are not very good at dealing with
complexity and and shades of gray
so how how are you going to fix it simon
working on it
[Laughter]
jeez all the pressure
the path that i've chosen
is to try and sit in the middle
where i think it's important to listen
i don't know if you know the work of dia
khan
she's a award-winning documentarian
muslim woman living in england
who is trolled by white supremacists
to the point where the police advised
her to stay away from open windows like
it got that bad yeah
the way she responded
was she moved to the united states and
went to meet white supremacists she was
in charlottesville she wasn't marching
with them but she was walking with them
she went to give white supremacists a
safe space to feel heard and she tells
the story of her own journey where she
went to the rallies and she spat on the
nazis and she felt self-righteous
she talked about it with all the people
who went to the rally and spat on the
nazis and held their signs and screamed
and yelled and called them racist and
they all felt great about themselves and
at the end of the day do you ask
yourself what did i do did i move the
needle did i actually affect them or did
i just feel good about myself
and she realized that screaming and
yelling and spitting at people
isn't the solution she made a
documentary about it called white right
meeting the enemy
and something remarkable happens
which is
she gives them a chance that she calls
it to empty the bucket at the point that
they feel heard they're willing to
listen to her and
they struggle to now reconcile their
racist views with the fact that they
trust her and view her as a friend and
one by one they drop out of the movement
what she's doing i think is
helpful i think it was great for those
nazis to sort of realize i shouldn't be
a nazi
okay
um
but what i also find is like i feel like
you we can't be in a place where we have
to center
ignorance and hatred and hold their hand
there's a part of me where it's like i
i don't i don't care if a nazi doesn't
feel heard because what you're spewing
is vitriol like as a person of a color
as a woman as just like a person who's
like not horrible to me it
it's wild that
what she's doing
is never done from the other side
like a white supremacist is like i let
me go talk to some mexicans and figure
out my [ __ ] it's never that it is
someone else having to do the work of
fixing
white patriarchal [ __ ] which i'm
like we are not here
to fix your your [ __ ] and fix this mess
you're right you're 100 right yeah and i
asked you that question and she said
she's worked with white supremacists
she's worked with jihadis she's worked
with abortion activists and
she said in in her work in her
experience the one lesson she's learned
agree or disagree like it or not is the
victim very often has to go first
and you're right you i shouldn't have to
the white patriarchy i shouldn't have to
fix their [ __ ] you're right but then
what how is someone who has a racist
point of view or a misogynistic point of
view
or who has supremacist thinking
how will they see the light if they
don't have an experience that helps them
see the light
that is a great question i think that's
super valid
but also i think it would be more
supportive of stuff like this even
though i think what she's doing is
brilliant and
smart and
necessary obviously
but what i find is
more often than not it tends to not be
sustained throughout history there have
been you know gay people people color
women
you know white dudes who who get it who
have done the work of educating this
group or that group and it's great for
like a movie that like you know hillary
swank will star in you know what i mean
but
but the
the fruits of the that labor never come
to pass
if it's not actually being sustained
through years and decades like i'm not
sure
what the work is actually doing in the
long term well i think you summed it up
the work
is constant
i mean you're in a relationship you're
in a four and a half year relationship
i never understood that like people like
relationships require work i'm like how
like how good is your relationship if
you're constantly working on it you know
and i'm in a relationship and let me
tell you it's a lot of work
but every day i wake up and say is this
work worth it and every day i say yes
and the minute it's not worth it then
i guess it'll collapse
yeah but the work is worth it
which is why i and we keep doing it and
it was if it was only me then it would
fall apart too
yeah you know to your point which is how
much do i have to keep doing this
but as you know in a relationship
one of you has to go first if you have a
debate or an argument or a fight
one of you has to say
i'm sorry
even if the other person's wrong
or can i tell you how i feel
and what happens when both parties stand
on the sides going you have to go first
although i refuse to
what happens and i'm not saying right or
wrong or good or bad i'm just asking the
question what happens in society when
both sides sit with their arms folded
and demand the other person to go first
you're right i mean we end up with the
the [ __ ] show that we're in right now
pretty much
a podcaster ain't gonna resolve this
can you tell me
something you've been involved in
that you absolutely loved
and if every project you worked on
if
everything you did was like this one
book this one special this one show
where this one script whatever that you
would be the happiest person alive
i i honestly so i'm in the middle of a
writer's room on my um show everything's
trash that's coming out on freeform
later this year and
it
is truly the best working experience
i've ever had
part of it is
because i started achieving success
career wise
or success the way that people would
view it
later you know what i mean like it
didn't happen for me when i was 21 25
like the the two double queens on hbo
happened when i was 33 going on 34. yeah
which is just a different mentality
you're much more appreciative
you've experienced more things not
working out than working out and
you know a lot of the writers in the
room they're in their 30s some are like
early 40s some have kids like everyone's
sort of like been through their own [ __ ]
and so when we all come into the room
we're sort of like
this is a goddamn privilege
like to be in this room and like create
and write and laugh with each other for
eight hours a day
we're not going to bring the [ __ ] in
we're not going to be competitive with
each other over like i want to say the
funniest like there's just a level of
like
we're adults and i think when you're an
adult you sort of kind of enjoy things i
think in a in a deeper way without the
sort of insecurities
lingering over it you've worked with
adults before though what makes this one
stand out that you're saying it's the
best working experience i've ever had i
mean you've worked with mature people
before what's so special about this one
i don't know if it's because of
the pandemic but there's just a level of
appreciation
and a genuine sort of
i want to feel good today and i also
want
you to feel good and i think that's
maybe something before the pandemic when
it was sort of like i i like i just want
to feel great like i don't really give a
[ __ ] how you feel and we're sort of like
no we want this to be good you know it's
sort of like when you have like good sex
and you're like both being like
this is tight as opposed to just one
person being like i'm getting mine the
other person's like
oh i have not gotten it yet i'm still
waiting you know what i mean and i think
that we want this together
which is nice tell me an early specific
happy childhood memory one of my
favorite like memories of just childhood
is just like
my brother's four years older than me
and he was always so generous and so he
would always just let me play with him
and his friends and it was just like
such a cool thing like he was never like
oh get out of here just be he just like
included me sort of in that there was
just no [ __ ] he was like i'm having
fun i want you to have fun too and i
could just like i closed my eyes and i
could just see us like in the backyard
playing basketball together and it's
just like he's such a cool dude
he's such a cool dude do you know that
the story you just told me about your
childhood in the story you just told me
about the writer's room or the exact
same story
what you just revealed
is basically your deep-seated motivation
your deep-seated inspiration what
energizes you which is what you said is
this mutual appreciation
you are become your brother it's not
just about him playing with his friends
and having fun and keeping his little
sister out it's about him having fun
with his friends and including his
little sister so she can have fun too
and that's how you describe the writer's
room it's not just about me having fun
but i want you to have fun too it's not
just about me finding success or
fulfillment or joy it's about you
finding it too
and your life's work now is to basically
invite other people to the basketball
court to play basketball with you oh my
i'm gonna tear up simon the way you just
encapsulated that
and i would argue that
that your best work
is the work that the message is about
appreciation inclusion and it's not just
about me it's about including you as
well
and like the messages in your work
when that comes through you will look at
your own work and be like i'm proud of
that work this was great oh my god
phoebe you're magic so are you
this is a dream this has been a true
dream the feeling's mutual what a joy
[Music]
if you enjoyed this podcast and would
like to hear more please subscribe
wherever you like to listen to podcasts
until then
take care of yourself
take care of each other